let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right well the media is digging for
an amy coney barrett scandal
and they just they they think they found
one finally
here's what they came up with this is
from the ap it says president donald
trump's nominee for the
u.s supreme court has close ties to a
charismatic christian religious group
that holds that men are divinely
ordained as the head of the family
former members of the group call people
of praise called people of praise say it
teaches that wives must submit to the
will of their husbands
federal appeals uh judge kamikota
barrett has not commented publicly
about her own or her family's
involvement uh
and uh so on and so forth but barrett 48
grew up in new orleans
and a family deeply connected to the
organization as recently as 2017 she
served as a trustee
at the people of praise-affiliated
trinity schools incorporated
people appraised as a religious
community based in charismatic
catholicism a movement that grew out of
the influence of pentecostal
pentecostalism which emphasizes a
personal relationship with jesus
barrett's affiliation with a
conservative religious group that
elevates the role of men
has drawn particular scrutiny given that
she would be filling the high court seat
held by justice ruth bader ginsburg a
feminist icon
barrett by contrast is being hailed by
religious conservatives as an
ideological heir to the late justice
scalia okay well so she belongs to a
group
that says that wives should submit to
their husbands um
horrifying horrifying stuff but but just
so you know
the the actual name of this
kooky fringe far-right group is
christians who believe in the bible okay
that that's that's the actual name
because well all christians who believe
in the bible believe this because
it's in the bible uh this is where you
see how the media
obviously they hate christians obviously
but they have difficulty smearing
christians effectively
because they don't know anything about
christianity
they're very biblically illiterate i bet
whoever wrote this
ap article for example didn't know that
the bible specifically says
wives submit to your husbands ephesians
5 22. one of my favorite verses by the
way
um and one that i will often cite to my
wife if we're
say arguing over what movie to watch on
a friday night
then i got to pull out the bible and say
it says it right here saint paul
what can i tell you okay it's not me
it's him he's telling you
but uh the media doesn't know that
that's why they don't nowhere in the
article is even mentioned that oh
this is how they interpret the bible
verse or not that there's any other way
to interpret it
because they just don't know that by the
way a devout catholic
quote unquote devout catholic joe biden
what about him
he also believes this right if he is if
he really is a devout catholic which he
isn't because he's pro-abortion you
can't be devout catholic and
pro-abortion but
let's just pretend for a moment as the
media wants us to pretend that he's
devout catholic well
in that case then he believes this too
and if we had a real news media
they would ask him about this they would
say hey uh
uh joe what what do you feel about this
ephesians 5
22. uh do you think wives should submit
to their husbands
i would love to see the way that he he
wiggles himself out of that but he's not
going to be put in that position because
he's not going to be asked about it
number two
tucker carlson had this report last
night
take a listen more and more lawmakers
are calling for a nationwide rule on
wearing face coverings
senator dianne feinstein has written to
federal agencies asking for a mandatory
mass policy
both in the air and on public transit
well that was news footage from june
just this june
when california senator dianne feinstein
wrote a letter to the faa
demanding everyone wear masks in
airports
feinstein wrote that we need a mandatory
mask policy for all airport and airline
employees
and passengers end quote feinstein
claimed the agency had quote sowed
confusion among passengers about whether
masks are necessary but they are
necessary says dianne feinstein
not wearing them is very dangerous given
the coronavirus
well given that today this show
exclusively obtained photographs of and
this is going to rock your world
dianne feinstein in a private terminal
at dulles airport
an fbo as they say in private aviation
on friday in the photographs feinstein
can be seen smiling without a mask on
one might even say she's showing
confusion about whether or not masks are
necessary
so there you go you know what annoys me
about these kinds of things aside from
the obvious
is the reaction from the public who
treat some in the public would treat
this sort of thing as a cheap gotcha
tactic you know criticizing feinstein
for not wearing a mask pelosi for
breaking the lockdown
rules mayor lightfoot de blasio etc so
many have done it
but the attitude from some citizens
namely ones with partisan bias in favor
of the party that keeps doing this
the reaction is to go oh come on you
know it's not that big of a deal
but it is a big deal it's a very big
deal
because these people have brought our
country to a standstill
have decimated the con the economy have
torn the constitution to shreds
imposing all these rules and laws on the
basis that they're doing it to save
lives
but their behavior reveals that they
don't really believe
their own reasoning they don't believe
the reasons that they are giving for any
of this
which raises an obvious question
why are they really doing it if they
don't believe it
then why are they doing it
once again going back to the first point
if we had a real news media this would
be a question that would be uh would be
asked
number three daily wire reports
transgender inmates in california will
now be
housed according to uh their gender
identity thanks to a new law
signed saturday by governor gavin newsom
the law states that prison
officers must privately ask inmates
going through the intake process if they
identify as transgender non-binary or
intersex
okay so every inmate who comes in is
gonna have to be asked now
hey are you are you non-binary
if the inmate indicates one of those
identities
they will be allowed to request a move
to the facility that houses their
preferred gender
oh my gosh this is
there is a caveat to the new law however
if the state has management or security
concerns it will provide a written
explanation of why it denied an inmate
the chance to be housed according to his
or her gender identity
um this exception is not included
because the state believes men will
claim to be women in order to harm
female inmates but because it believes
male inmates will attack
biological women to identify as men who
identify as men
okay well i mean what could possibly go
wrong here so so now
according to this it sounds like
um they're going to ask each inmate so
you know
what could go wrong when you go up to an
inmate and say hey by the way um
you go to a male inmate biologically
male
hey are you um you have are you actually
a woman because if you are you can go
over to the women's prison
just just let us know hey honor system
oh but that will never be exploited
right
you see again how this just um
how the the
for all of the the talk we hear about on
the left and democrats so they care so
much about women's rights and protecting
women
they don't give a damn they they don't
give the slightest damn
at least when when women's rights their
actual rights
okay um are are put up against
the lgbt agenda you know because there
is this hierarchy this intersectional
hierarchy this victimhood hierarchy that
we've talked about
and women are really pretty low on
on the on the hierarchy scale lgbt
they're above them
so their concerns and their desires come
first
so we're going to throw their safety out
the window their privacy out the window
and uh
if you know you got a bunch of male
prisoners that say oh yeah sure
i'm i'm a female yeah in fact i i woke
up
yesterday and realized i was a female as
it turns out so yeah
go ahead and send me over to the women's
prison
number four npr reports um
young adults are known for taking to the
streets in protest now there's a
youth-driven push to bring more of them
to the ballot box
tyler okiki a 19 year old activist is
among those who champion lowering the
voting age from 18 to 16.
okiki is working to increase the number
of eligible voters in in the country's
most diverse
generation and amplify their voices on
decisions that will affect their future
uh and then it goes on from there
talking about his his efforts to lower
the voting age to 16.
there's of course absolutely no good
reason to even consider lowering the
voting age
to 16 or lowering it at all to any age
if anything we should be raising it
the only reason why it's being
considered is that it would help
democrats which is not a good reason
unless you are a democrat and then
i can see why you'd be in favor of it
but in reality objectively
our republic cannot at all be helped by
this
the last thing we need are more people
who are ignorant and non-contributing
filing into the voting booth that's
that's the last thing we do we don't
need more of them
if you're 16 years old and i say this
and anyone
who's over the age of 16 you know this
too because you have
had the experience of being 16.
would you say at 16 that you were really
in touch like
you understood was happening in the
country you had a you had a really solid
perspective
um and you were real contributing member
of society you were emotionally and
mentally mature would you say that about
yourself at the age of 16
because because if you would then all
that tells me is that you haven't grown
at all from the age of 16
which means that you probably shouldn't
be able to vote now whatever age you are
but anyone who's done any growing any
maturing which maybe is a dwindling
minority
uh we can look back at ourselves at 16
and say no don't give
you give that person the right to vote
are you crazy
no raise the voting age to 25 raise it
to 35.
well i'm not 35 yet so i don't do that
just raise it raise it raise it to right
where i'm at and then
and then as i as i get older we can keep
raising it along with me
that's the way the law should work
number five important report from the
daily mirror um
a group of parrots at a zoo had to be
put back into isolation when they all
started swearing at customers after
coming out of quarantine
the five african gray parrots were
adopted by lincolnshire wildlife park on
august 15th and put into a room together
but it appears they used their time in
isolation
teaching each other foul language which
left park staff in hysterics but swift
action had to be taken
when they started using obscenities with
guests steve nichols
ceo at the frisney park said the birds
were put in a time out but admitted over
the last 25 years
he's taken in many parents parrots that
have sometimes had a bit of blue
language
he told lincolnshire live every now and
then you'll get one that swears and it's
always funny we always find it very
comical when they do swear at you
but then he continues that the problem
is that now they're they're they are um
swearing at uh guests and there's a
concern that especially with children
coming back to the zoo they're gonna
start swearing at the kids be very
traumatizing
to get cussed out by a parrot and so now
they're isolating the parrots and
they're actually gonna break them up
and put the parrots with more
responsible each each of the five
bad parents delinquent parents pet
parrots will go with with one of the
responsible parrots
and then hopefully there will be some
you know they'll speaking of maturing
they'll learn to mature that way
a very disturbing report all around and
a pretty
serious infringement on free speech i
don't remember anything in the
constitution
saying that you can't swear a guess
at a zoo i don't seem to recall that in
there
of course this is a british zoo and
these are parrots
but i don't see how that has any
relevance to the legal case i'm making
here
and besides you can't blame them for
swearing um i'd be a little salty too if
i was locked in a zoo
and if i was a parrot frankly as well
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated